[Music]
we're in a car train let's go to the
Swiss
outs there's no one at the
wheel there he
is it's a little scary in here
now
come on guy got a helicopter to
[Music]
[Applause]
catch
travel to Switzerland and an obvious
thought will hit you the country can
feel too
[Applause]
perfect the
cities the
watches the city's with
watches the
Lakes the
mountains Roger Federer
the ideal
[Applause]
man it's also well made either by humans
or by Nature it's
almost
boring and it's true that there is a
museum like quality to
Switzerland it feels like they figured
everything
out then stopped
[Music]
but let me offer an alternative
view because in Switzerland you can also
find the shock of the new and
unexpected the country aims a large
portion of its considerable wealth at
universities and research
institutions these places are doing
fantastic work in fields like robotics
Ai and in
medicine and Switzerland is also a
country that welcomes immigrants at
least crazy smart immigrants and helps
them create startups from their
research let's go meet
one
wow they are
[Music]
everywhere
like if I did hit one would it just try
to get back
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah and it just finds its location
again yeah
[Music]
exactly the worst thing that could
happen is that somehow the propeller
hits your eyeball yeah why did you say
that
on this show we tend to feature people
who are
exceptional but The Man Behind These
drones is unusual even among the
[Music]
exceptional my name is rafaelo Dandrea
everybody calls me Raph I'm a professor
at eth Zurich and I'm also the CEO and
founder of
verity Raph is part math genius
part robotics Pioneer and part artist oh
yeah you can actually give it a good
good shove yep it balances amazing and
not only can It balance it can actually
rotate and balance at the same time no
way it's very delicate what it does so
I'm scared to
[Laughter]
move the cube was
cool then he supersized
it so this is the balancing Cube and the
the goal here is for this to stay
upright and Balan ex
exactly it changes its position so it
changes the center of Mass to compensate
for movement so inside I'm seeing like
Motors and circuit boards there's Motors
there's sensors and actually what you
don't see is that these are all
communicating to each
other raph's talent for engineering has
made him a very wealthy man in 2003 he
co-founded Kaa systems a robotics
company specializing in Warehouse
Automation in 2012 Amazon acquired Kaa
for almost $800
million for someone who's into so many
things you it must have changed your
life to have this Amazon buy the company
and then you you get to chase whatever
you want really right yeah I think uh
I've been fortunate that I've been able
to do what I want to
do
this is how we tested the first
versions yeah that's me right there
okay Raph discovered his passion early
in
life he was born in Italy then moved to
Canada at 10: and quickly developed into
a budding mad scientist I did some
stupid things I learned about pressure
by jumping into a swimming pool with a
hose in my mouth I jumped off the roof
of my house with an umbrella a lawn
umbrella because I wanted to be like a
parachute did you break anything on that
no I didn't it was you know a Canada
Bungalow only 10 ft but it's a what a
great way to learn something by actually
putting yourself in the experiment he
miraculously survived to adulthood
worked and taught in the United States
and then for good reason settled in
Zurich I've heard Zurich is known as
drone Valley or something like that or
is that right yeah we're uh there is a
lot of activity in autonomous systems in
general Switzerland is known for doing a
lot of cool stuff with drones when we
started doing drone research in 2018
that was still kind of early days for
drones and there we were really aimed at
pushing the boundary of autonomous
flight so we did a lot of crazy stuff
with pole balancing and playing ping
pong and a whole bunch of other fun
things it was a way to motivate the
researchers if we can make something
that makes people go wow that's amazing
then we know we've pushed the
boundary
[Music]
to commercialize his acrobatic drones
Raph started a new company called Verity
in
2014 they made their artsy
machines and then oddly began chasing
that sweet sweet warehouse management
money as well hoping to replace fallible
humans with a fully automated
system people hate doing inventory
control it is a detested task as a
result people don't do inventory nearly
as often as they should and they live
with these heirs in a warehouse that has
you know $100 million of throughput and
there's a 3 or 4% error in that
warehouse that's a significant amount
sure to help fix some of the costly
mistakes farity can send over some of
its drones to work the night shift the
drones fly when there's no one there and
then the system synchronizes with the
warehouse management system and then
creates a list of all the things that
need to be
fixed Raph showed me the aerial Auditors
in
[Music]
action it's doing these very F
adjustments to make sure that it's in
the right spot of where it needs to be
to take the
image Verity's Warehouse drones have
been pretty successful Landing customers
like Ikea and Samsung
they raised a $32 million funding round
in early
2023 and these drones can do a lot more
than scan QR codes our entertainment
business is less than 10% of what we do
but it's an important part of what we do
it's it's in our DNA you know doing
things when failure is not an
option to rafh whether he's flying his
flock past 10,000 boxes of liquid soap
or over the heads of 10,000 Spellbound
spectators very little changes you know
for me the Act of Creation is what I
really enjoy um and the nice thing about
technology and specifically Robotics and
AI is that whether it's art whether it's
industrial practice whether it's
research it's all about taking something
and making it do motion that hasn't been
done before through
mathematics this is only 16 can you
imagine when you have 200 of them yeah I
feel like I'm in amid some night stream
it is magical you know we take it for
granted cuz we do it all the time but it
is amazing that intelligent monkeys can
do this
[Laughter]
[Music]
right it could be the case that crazy
flying robots don't do it for you I
understand
[Music]
ish and so I have prepared for you
something more sci-fi more medical more
epidermis welcome to cus purveyors of
the finest lab grown human
skin founder Daniela Marino is another
immigrant turning Swiss R&D into a
startup she formed cutus in 2017 hoping
to transform the way we treat severe
skin damage if I had a burn an accident
what would be the standard thing that
happens today so if you today get burned
severely so uh you lost quite a
sustention amount of your skin uh you
are in danger of Life first thing so you
are admitted in very specialized burn
units when your body is ready and out of
danger of of risking your life
autografting starts autografting means
that the surgeon takes skin from
somewhere else not burnt on your body
and puts it on the wounds if the wounds
are very large it is a clinical
challenge to actually find enough skin
so what we do is trying to shift the
Paradigm but towards saying okay give me
a little piece from somewhere and I take
it to the lab and I'll make it bigger
and ship it to you back we receive a
piece of skin of the patient as small as
a stem and then we can extract the stem
cells expand them and then recreate skin
using a bioengineering technique
[Music]
when the skin is done growing it looks
something like
this
[Music]
delicious this is both cool and slightly
creepy isn't it
no you haven't seen anything creepy for
real in your life then like how is look
different to the final product when it's
the final one is a bit thicker and it
will be much more more resistant because
you have all the cells that keep it
together I mean the one major limiting
factor it seems right now is is the
pigmentation and the skin what's the
plan for addressing that so at the
moment we don't have melanoides in the
culture which means we have we are
missing the cells that produce the
melanin and we are now having an add-on
therapy to then simply transfer the
melanocytes from somewhere colored to
the wide area and produce a melanin
which will match the color of the
patient so far Daniela and her team have
treated 50 patients in clinical trials
including in one case a newborn so this
is youngest child ever treated with
bioengineered skin and you can imagine
the growth of a kid 5 days old and now 2
and 1/2 years later I mean the stretch
is just humongous and it's impressive to
see the result
if all goes well Daniela wants to have
her skin growing machines set up around
the world not just limited to hospitals
but in oil rigs commercial kitchens and
War
zones as ever with biotech these things
take time and lots of money luckily
Switzerland adors its science startups
and lavishes them with resources you
have a a mixture of a brain Force here
which is incredible
and next to this Innovative Hub you have
a very strong startup ecosystem so I
don't know if I would have been that
successful to creating ctis in my
homeland Italy or somewhere else because
here you really are a nurtured as a
startup yeah cuz there's not that many
countries I think where you could raise
the amount of money it would take to a
company that has to have a few years to
get going because of all the clinical
trials and longterm investment for sure
are not willing to kind of sit through
that this is a very very expensive
Journey
journey and there is no plan B I mean it
has to be like that so um let's see I
hope I continue raising the money I
need if she's able to bring the
technology to Market it could impact
Millions upon millions of
lives I just hope that after my next
adventure I don't require her Services
we're flying straight into the mountain
scary
Zurich is a lovely
town but this is Switzerland and there
are natural wonders to
see I'm told there's nothing like
soaring around the Alps in a
helicopter however dodging cags in a
metal cage is somewhat well extremely
terrifying mostly because I'm not a
pilot and I don't want to start learning
at 13,000
ft as it happens however I am that lucky
tourist who knows a guy who can make all
of my sightseeing dreams come true my
name is Fabby reason uh I have the
pleasure to be uh the CEO of uh love
Dynamics
company basically I LOF is producing the
world's first fly simulator training
device using virtual
technology okay so it's kind of like a
truthfully I'm a bit of a flight
simulator
veteran but even at the high-end
training centers pretend flying still
has its limitations you go to NASA or
something and you expect it to be space
Agy and Cutting Edge but the the
simulators always look like they were
built in in like the 1980s I mean it it
seems like technology that hasn't
changed in a long time yeah those
gigantic domes give you a very nice view
but the main challenge is everything
outside is projected so if you have uh
two objects um behind each other and you
move the head you kind of like see that
they are moving against each other on
the Dome projection nothing happens with
virtual reality this is basically not
the case anymore and uh it's like real
uh from a visual point of
view Fab built his first VR simulator in
his living room earning himself the
title of greatest dad of all
time he eventually upgraded to a real
Workshop swis
quality does this all this all gets made
in Switzerland here or yeah okay the
simulator sell for under a million bucks
way less than a traditional Dome type
Sim which is good because the world
needs a lot more of these things let's
talk about the pilot shortage a bit I
mean it it seems like there's not enough
pilots and then there's just a ton of
training both for new pilots and older
Pilots right to to keep their skills up
is that the general idea yes on one hand
it's uh quite expensive uh to to use the
real aircraft to do it and on the other
hand the simulators are also expensive
and there are simply not enough
simulators so we are continuously below
the actual needs from the
pilots the true test was giving one of
these whirly Birds a
World get to the
chopper and we're going to give you a
bit of forward speed this is
cool all right I'll give you the control
in three 2 1 your
control do I need to get higher to get
um yeah you need to get higher because
you want to get over that hill so keep
keep keep pulling keep pulling that's
good
oh
boy Whoa okay I'm going to take the I'm
going to take the
controls we haven't even started with
the
pedals wait what do the pedals actually
dooo you know what let's make him uh
land the
aircraft okay okay wo wo wo you're going
to crash into the building but you're
going down really fast okay
okay now you managed to
[Music]
crash as far as I was concerned I had
officially graduated Swiss flight school
I blame
you now it was time to try the real
[Music]
thing so Fabby sent me on a 4-Hour drive
into the Alps destination zermat a
Charming mountain town where we could
take off and cruise CR the skies
together we're at air zerat the matter
horn is just over there I'm going to
meet up with Bobby and I think he's
getting here right
[Music]
[Applause]
now coming style
huh With a Little Help from Ace pilot
Julie like that good it was time to put
my skills to the test
[Applause]
you want to try a little bit on what
is really really slowly okay your
control Ashley have you realized she's
not holding anym the control it's fully
your
control don't don't tell me that
please
you're not breathing you have to
[Music]
breathe you see you're Turing yourself
did I actually just do that or did you
help oh no no you did it no way all I
don't like it when we get so close to
the rout though then I
get
can I come with you now okay yes please
we could just
there exciting and terrifying at the
same
time I actually flew it was really
cool before heading home Fabby insisted
I meet his buddy Mario a mysterious
mountain man who's invested in some of
the best tech startups in Switzerland
including fabes KNN not knock
on come in Mario how are you doing good
to see you guys hello pleasure to see
you nice to meet you War welome sit down
beer chonic what do you
[Music]
like Mario had all the trappings of an
eccentric free spirit right down to his
underground secret passageway and Spa
watch your head here okay first this is
the uh Wellness area and this is where I
have the wine and spirits
yeah so that's the matter horn right out
the window that's the mother horn right
there and uh of course I know a lot of
rich people and whatever and they are
impressed by the house so they offer me
tons of money for this house and what do
you tell them I tell them not on sale
and never on sale this here is my house
and that's where my spirit is living and
giving me opportunities to be
creative Mario was born in zermat and
has lived many lives restaurant Tour
hotelier mountain climber ski instructor
and eventually Tech investor stiring the
Fun de I feel like now I get Swiss
citizenship if you manage to reach his
Fortress of
Solitude he is a gracious host cheers so
nice meting than invting us into your
home of you appreciate it Mario told me
about some of the ventures he has in the
works first we make a carbon fiber out
of algae we reinforce this with stone
and then he told me about them some more
this is not Rusty it cannot you can
imagine what impact this is having on
construction also for the key industry
my goal is now to build the house
completely CO2 neutral even negative
this would be sexy yeah it has to be
sexy so you've been to the North Pole
the South Pole you've climbed the eight
highest peaks right at traversing
Everest when I'm doing Expeditions I can
calm down because I think one day I will
be crazy I'm enough crazy already but I
feel like you calm down by doing more
stuff yes but it is running on high
speeds because it seemed that Mario was
a kind of spirit animal of the Swiss
texi
this I can moving at hypers speed
embracing new ideas flush with cash and
perched a top a majestic Alp bless this
[Music]
country but this wasn't the end of my
Swiss
Journey it was time to trade in my
helicopter for a bicycle and take a mind
expanding
trip
[Music]